qu'est-il arrivé à sophie lyonnais 7
auboise de 21 ans fille au pair dans la
banlieue de londres le 20 septembre son
corps est retrouvé calciné dans le
jardin d'une propriété de wimbledon
la jeune fille s'occupait des deux
enfants d'un couple franco algérien
selon ses proches elle envisageait de
rentrer en france
elle adorait vraiment les enfants elle
adorait son travail après son vécu là
bas c'est vrai qu'elle voulait rentrer
ça faisait un moment qu'elle voulait
rentrer elle devait revenir au mois de
juillet apparemment été retenus là bas
rapidement les soupçons se portent sur
ses employeurs où ils s'aiment mais doni
40 on ait sabrina kouider 34 ans que le
couple a reconnu avoir fait disparaître
le corps mais nie l'avoir tué que s'est
il passé quelles étaient les conditions
de vie de sophie lyonnais etait-elle
maltraiter ses parents sa mère veulent
comprendre
j'aimerais bien savoir comment comment
ça s'est passé comment ils en sont venus
là parce que à plusieurs reprises je me
suis dit et j'ai dit à cette personne
quand j'ai eu au téléphone
si ça va pas avec sophie qu'elle rentre
ce drame a suscité une vive émotion
auprès des jeunes filles au pair le 8
octobre une marche blanche était
organisée à londres en mémoire de sophie
lyonnais le procès pourrait durer cinq
semaines
les accusés risquent la prison à vie